SIDE.
SHOT, BIG SAVED!
EARLY OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
KRAKEN!
WE GET
SHOT,  ROCKED AS HE RELEASED
THAT SHOT AND THEN GRUBAUER THE
NATHAN BASAS
GRUBAUER.
MISSED SCORING OPPORTUNITY
THERE, MERE INCHES AWAY.
SCORES!SHOT
OF
IS STOPPED.
DEMKO GOT OVER THERE, DRIVE JOHN
THE VANCOUVER KRAKEN!
POINT, REACHED GARLAND.
GARLAND SPENDS THAT PUCK INTO
THROUGH THE TRAFFIC, LOOSE PUCK
BECAUSE IT'S ALL BEEN IN FRONT
WITH DEMKO.
WATCH THIS STOP BY DEMKO.
HE'S GONNA FIGHOFF FOR A BREAK!
IT DEMKO MAKES THE SAVE AND,
MOMENTS LATER, SEATTLE TAKEKEGO
POSITIONING IN THE END.
>>
OF DEMKO AND LARSSON.
THE
NIGHT!
WITH 7:08 TO PLAY IN THE THIRIR
TO PLAY AS IT DEFLECTS OFF
GRUBAUER ANAN.
LOOSE PUCK PICKED UP  BY
GRUBAUER PUTS HIS HEAD IN THE
AIR, HE KNOWS HE EMPTY S THE BL
ON SIDE.